president trump has responded he has
just released a video this is a white
house video
from the oval office this was not in the
pool there were not reporters in the
room this is a white house video
but it is in response to the impeachment
vote and we want to play it for you on
special report
my fellow americans i want to speak to
you tonight
about the troubling events of the past
week
as i have said the incursion of the u.s
capitol struck at the very heart
of our republic it angered and appalled
millions of americans across the
political spectrum
i want to be very clear i unequivocally
condemned the violence that we saw last
week
violence and vandalism have absolutely
no place in our country
and no place in our movement making
america great again has always been
about defending
the rule of law supporting the men and
women of law enforcement
and upholding our nation's most sacred
traditions and values
mob violence goes against everything i
believe in
and everything our movement stands for
no true supporter of mind could ever
endorse
political violence no true supporter of
mine could ever disrespect
law enforcement or our great american
flag
no true supporter of mind could ever
threaten or harass their fellow
americans
if you do any of these things you are
not supporting our movement
you are attacking it and you are
attacking our
country we cannot tolerate it
tragically over the course of the past
year
made so difficult because of covet 19
we have seen political violence spiral
out of control we have seen too many
riots too many mobs
too many acts of intimidation and
destruction
it must stop whether you are on the
right
or on the left a democrat
or a republican there is never
a justification for violence
no excuses no exceptions
america is a nation of laws
those who engaged in the attacks last
week
will be brought to justice now i am
asking everyone who has
ever believed in our agenda to be
thinking of ways to ease tensions
calm tempers and help to promote peace
in our country there has been reporting
that additional demonstrations are being
planned
in the coming days both here in
washington
and across the country
i have been briefed by the u.s secret
service
on the potential threats every american
deserves to have their voice heard
in a respectful and peaceful way that is
your first
amendment right but i cannot emphasize
that there must be no violence no law
breaking
and no vandalism of any kind everyone
must follow our laws
and obey the instructions of law
enforcement
i have directed federal agencies to use
all
necessary resources to maintain order
in washington dc we are bringing in
thousands of national guard members
to secure the city and ensure that a
transition can occur
safely and without incident like all of
you i was shocked and deeply saddened by
the
calamity at the capitol last week
i want to thank the hundreds of millions
of incredible american citizens
who have responded to this moment with
calm moderation
and grace we will get through this
challenge
just like we always do i also want to
say
a few words about the unprecedented
assault
on free speech we have seen in recent
days
these are tense and difficult times the
efforts to
censor cancel and blacklist our fellow
citizens
are wrong and they are dangerous
what is needed now is for us to listen
to one another
not to silence one another
all of us can choose by our actions to
rise
above the rancor and find common ground
and
shared purpose we must focus on
advancing the interests of the whole
nation
delivering the miracle vaccines
defeating the pandemic rebuilding the
economy
protecting our national security and
upholding
the rule of law today i am calling on
all americans to overcome the passions
of the
moment and join together as one
american people let us choose to move
forward united
for the good of our families our
communities
and our country thank you god bless you
and god bless america
president donald trump in the oval
office with a message
again a white house video we just
received playing for you
here on special report white house chief
white house correspondent john roberts
live on the north lawn with reaction uh
good evening john it's the
longest response we've heard and
obviously uh the message the president
wanted to get out tonight
just about five minutes and 13 seconds
long this was something that was put
together
after the impeachment vote came down in
the house but notable
that the president did not talk at all
about impeachment
something that he just yesterday
referred to as a continuation
of the years-long witch-hunt but the
president talking about the violence
saying that
no supporter of his would ever threaten
or harass
their fellow americans that he
unequivocally condemns the violence
and that he has authorized all force
necessary
to prevent any further violence in
imploring his supporters
to go forward in peace and that there be
no violence
that there be no vandalism nothing like
that between now
and the inauguration and beyond the
question
now is bret where do we go in terms of
impeachment will there be a trial in the
senate
as was pointed out earlier senator mitch
mcconnell has said that there's no time
to do it before the inauguration of joe
biden
i do know that the president's aides
have reached out to outside counsel to
see who might be available
should a trial occur in the in the
senate i am told that
the president's last impeachment team
pat cipolloni patrick philbin
jay sekulow and pam bondi would not be
signing up for
another drink at the well other outside
council i'm told has politely declined
as well it is possible
that rudy giuliani may be a
constitutional expert named john
eastman and potentially alan dershowitz
could be involved if this one goes to
trial in the senate but the big question
is whether it ever gets there because
the white house aides told me today
that if this doesn't happen quickly then
the momentum for a trial
becomes less and less and if this gets
pushed out to
as congressman james clyburn of south
carolina suggested
after joe biden's first 100 days they
believed that the
potential for a conviction in the senate
would be greatly diminished right
john it's pretty stark the difference
between the speech
he delivered last wednesday on the mall
and that message that we heard tonight
and obviously a lot has transpired in
between
but it's notable yeah i mean there's
even a difference between
what we heard tonight what we heard
yesterday yesterday as he was at joint
base andrews about to board air force
one
the president said that his speech on
the ellipse a week ago
has been analyzed and was found to be
totally appropriate
i don't think you'd find many people who
would agree with that assessment but but
the president
uh he didn't seem quite contrite
today he didn't acknowledge that he had
any responsibility for it as the
minority leader kevin mccarthy
said on the floor of the house he said
that the president does bear some
responsibility for it
but the president going i think further
than he has before saying that he was
shocked and saddened by the calamity but
there are a lot of people in america who
would say that he is at least partly
responsible for that calamity